well happy birthday jesus sorry your
party's so lame
what is this happy holidays dwight
but do not open it till christmas you
were so pathetic how long did this take
you three hours five minutes actually
i am a black belt in gift wrapping yeah
no such thing they don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid
well i hope it was worth it because i'm
gonna take it apart in about five
minutes
i think it'll take you a little bit
longer than that really if i can skin a
mule deer in less than 10 minutes i
ought to be able to cut my
phyllis is only
pretending to be a man i'm the real
thing
sit down on my lap and there will be no
doubt oh okay no it's not it's not like
penis-wise hello little boy what's your
name michael it's me kevin
phyllis says i'm too big for her lap oh
i am so sorry that phyllis hates you
and hates your body
but santa remembers a reindeer that was
just a tiny bit different as well when
can i sit on your lap right now come on
over here big boy
there we go oh my
that's god comfortable
what would you like a christmas little
boy
i don't know
i i didn't know you were gonna ask me
that wow what did you think was going to
happen i didn't know oh nobody's ever
let me sit on their lap before just say
some toys please
can you give me some choices cause i
really don't want to mess up on this
list
kevin come on what about if i tell you
the things i don't want okay get off get
off
oh god i didn't even get to tell you
what i wanted okay you know what you get
you get a thousand helium balloons
attached to you so santa doesn't have to
go through this again
awesome
i really want the ipod okay okay it's
already been stolen this round pick
something else i hope nobody takes this
baby because
this is great wow look at that fine
craftsmanship
and you really put a lot of work into
that it's beautiful
i'll take the oven mitt
sorry guys sorry guys i'm not sure i've
earned the right to make announcements
yet but whoever is giving me the 12 days
of christmas as my secret santa
please stop
i can't take it anymore
my cat killed a turtle dove the french
hens have started pulling out my hair to
make a nest please stop
what psycho would send that as a gift
i begged dwight and jim to give me aaron
for secret santa and i decided to give
aaron the 12 days of christmas
is it my fault that the first eight days
is basically 30 birds
[Music]
120 180
200. all right oh thank you so much my
daughter is going to love this wow so
glad i could help thanks merry christmas
you too
oh so this is what every day would be
like if you hadn't left india
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
all right
[Music]
hey meredith heading over to port
richards yep
cool cool you need a ride
all right let's head out
sounds good you have a coat
yeah oh
okay you can't click on these kardashian
links that's why you have so many
viruses well help me okay i'm trying but
you need to come yep game on
[Laughter]
did you just fart
and that is how it's done
attention everyone
jim and i on behalf of the party
planning committee
too loud but effective look on behalf of
jim and i merry christmas
merry christmas good my diabolical plot
is on hold for christmas
my heart
just melts with the sound of children
singing
not really
i'm just tired the days are short i
don't know
maybe i'm depressed
it is time to unveil the tree
rockefeller center yeah
uh i've actually been to rock center and
this is nothing like that this is all we
have ugh nope it's not ugh
it is office camaraderie it is warm
feelings why don't we talk more about it
instead of doing it 30
29
28. why would you start something 27 3
22 1.
you didn't decorate it no exactly we
didn't because we think it would be
better to do it together everyone why
would you wrap it in a sheet if you're
not covering anything up
is is it fake pam yeah yes we are
unveiling an artificial tree that will
never die yes like the spirit
of christmas we're supposed to applaud
you for taking a giant dab off a fake
tree this was a successful unveiling go
back to work merry christmas
you've reached the voicemail of dwight
kurt schrute please leave
ah
[Music]
i have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but i think it was worth it
come on
um i was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept
throwing him
until he exhausted himself
and uh
then
how about icing it lol dwight
i love this hog mama dwight said it's
hog ma
what is more
like everybody's attention
christmas is cancelled you can't cancel
a holiday give it up stanley and you
will lose new year's what does that mean
jim take new year's away from stanley
michael
hey oh hello there
what are you doing
i don't know
you shouldn't do things like that
the man is supposed to do that
[Music]
ah
[Music]
this garbage
[Music]
this is christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you